alors c'est un toc toc toc spéciale pour
des visuels spécial chanteur bien
entendu alors oui qu'est la mousse a
dénoncé pas mousse et maxime gagné je te
reconnais pas tiens tiens et la mousse
acoustique où sont les femmes
comme tu te regardes et tu as disparaît
sais pas qui vous ressemblent mvoum
angoissé c'est un mélange de claude
françois et de et de chevalier laspalès
plus tôt et ça exactement les cff
mais vous savez beaucoup de l'afp ales e
à bonjour oui merci au revoir à tokyo
j'entends pas du toc toc toc toc toc toc
et la sedane d'anti danois tam
juste mais bien et les banques demeurent
tant pis on va bien récupérer leurs
familles maison appartient en tant
qu'acteur quote c'est parti toc toc toc
j'ai reconnu la voix noël noël qui noël
mamère m'a dit antoine fait 3 coupé les
cheveux
il est recyclable à espère s'y arrête un
mentor
je suis calme plat jean-louis troisième
place qu'on voulait soit à côté
d'isabelle au milieu on l'a ratée au
milieu d'accord ça dérange pas du tout
parce que nous on voulait vraiment
mettre entre à gap il avait lancé c'est
bien le mérite et ça va bien très bien
ah ouais bah merde et on verra si on
change de place au pas tous d'accord
pour l'instant tout c'était une très
belle touffe merci on les bat répartie
alors rien à la façon de toqué c'est
très classe vous avez une idée ouais
c'est pas mal à nos proulx madame ou un
gâteau poway je ne sens pas un gâteau
promo qui est là étienne agathe a changé
de boire au caire isiro fait le docteur
qui est là étienne un thème qui le
tiennent bon la barre et tient bon
tu as
2 0
le vent s'est senti à l'eau dévient de
400 tonneaux la suite r10 est ma que
face à son préféré c'est aussi j'adore
jean luc lemoine elle a bercy c'est pas
qu'il y ait taktak faut dire le toc toc
toc toc toc toc qui est là c'est jean
jean qui sous la halle à buffalo un
rapport qui n'est besoin de par
seulement à des tarifs
quoi qu'il arrive n'importe quelle
chanson effet toujours la même dans
celle ci mais ça c'est pas danser c'est
vrai oui alors oui mais c'est non mais
vous avez un problème de dents tu vous
faire prendre des cours de danse
merci et à très bien ça non mais c'est
vrai modern jazz c'est là où intervient
on a dit de dire que pierre était plutôt
de ce côté là on verra ça tout à l'heure
à l'enquêté pas est-ce que vous pouvez
pas nous faire une petite danse
aujourd'hui j'ai pu non je pense que
vous avez compris que c'était une
boutade mais on est en soirée ne faisait
pas obligés de lancer comme des oufs
mais voilà comment vous danser tous les
deux on en soirée voilà comment vous
dansiez voilà
et les deux on sent qu'à une ambiance
donc facettes soir hier je veux bien
dans ses puces mais faut mettre un pied
dans le slip est allé tac tac
tu es là tu m'aimes pas reconnu la bois
en vrai moi toc toc toc qu'elle a c'est
léger qui ça gg gégé qui j'ai crié allez
au caire
je ferai
je me suis assis parfois radar mois
3 elle a disparu
j'ai une question oui mon entrain de
chanter là les années 80 le thème danse
a rien à voir c'est achetant des têtes
de bois d'ailleurs si tu connais pas
l'émission on va trop dire turc et sur
le canal football club avec ses fans et
80 du tout qui vous a dit ça c'est
plutôt années 70 ce même directement
merci alors mais c'est à moi sont là on
est largué à 110,70 lalalalala vais donc
vous comme ici c'est chanson j'adore je
connais tous par coeur
j'ai tout regardé beaucoup les ânes
études avec jean pierre foucault et moi
qui vais la troupe roger louret et les
années 60
souvenirs souvenirs
ah oui les gens d'ailleurs oui je sais
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de public qui va
arriver encore les chéris parce que
christophe apparemment à faire une
grosse entrée ouais c'est ce qu'on m'a
dit donc est ce qu'on peut avoir d une
caméra est ce qu'on peut avoir à prendre
car voilà qui est encore une caméra
merci parce qu'il paraît que c'est la
folie donc c'était quoi souvenirs flous
je vous retrouve en mon coeur et me
faire refleurir tous ces chefs de
bonheur je me souviens
il
chaque attaque allez-y ok on sait que
c'est gilles verdez n'ont pas voulu
ouvrir on va pas se voir on va pas se
raconter d'histoires les cherry s'est
bien gilles verdez 25
c'est yves par le libéro pas le vivre
il venait d'avoir 18 ans
comme un homme
c'est fait
et
deux ans
m
c'est vrai
je vous le dis et je sais que je suis
pas fan normalement quand tu fais des
happenings c'est le dom juan
enfin le précieux d'octobre a dit vadim
rythme a dit on fait prochain toc toc
toc attention c'est parti
enfin ils rappellent par ab il va pas me
lâcher allez c'est parti on y va oui oui
aulas va pas bien je vais taper comme ça
c'est une porte qu'on est nous a coûté
une petite fortune qui est là gilles
bailly d'idées la cgil qui gèlerait bien
refaire tout
vous
access et
pourquoi tu fais un bébé n'est pas ce
que je viens de me voir dans la glace
ouais mais là c'est là et là que l'art
la la la la
la la
il y a
seymour jetez pas votre meilleur c'est
parti ah bah c'est la dernière
qu'est ce qui l'attend pas c'est ma main
c'est qui baba j'entends pas mais
redknapp a demandé rentrée si j'avais
envie bah oui mais vous êtes en train de
faire un fiasco
je te le dis que tu te concentres ne va
pas le faire fait rien c'est bon c'est
reggae à doser partie allez-y mactac
semana attendez attendez on voter
allez-y en fait le top 5
ça fait chier de répondre
allez-y en fait l'on n'a pas entendu tac
tac tac à la twa gens non non non
attendez attendez attendez
attention attendez attendez attendez
attendez attendez isabelle à les
isabelle aubret j'écrivais je vois un
sens sans label ce que je vais faire au
match
c'est pas tout seul en fin d'émission le
plus long jeudi soir m isabelle quand tu
vas pouvoir le faire là ok elle pense
aussi où le fait à fond ouais d'accord
même où le fatah faut vous le fait à
fond c'est bon c'est bon vous êtes
prêtre oui alors allez-y tac tac tac tac
tac attendait deux minutes à olemps fait
on leur fait tu attaques
allez on l'a fait oui on la refait toute
attaque non plus fort qui tape attaque
wiki et là c'est mama ba ba ba ba ba qui
maillot
qu'est ce qu'il ya sous tendre un
chapeau il ya un gros cerveau
isabelle rheault
gr
ça